مع العلم أن إيران وروسيا تواجهان الآن
عقوبات من الولايات المتحدة من
الاتحاد الأوروبي ، وكذلك
كيف ترون تأثير هذه
العقوبات على دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي وعلى
ألاباما
أيضًا ، فإن الوضع برمته مرتبك وغير مستقر
وديناميكي ، لذلك من الصعب قول
شيء ما  اليوم لن يكون هذا خطأ
غدًا ، لكنني سأحاول بالتأكيد على أي حال ، فإن
الحرب ككل تعطل
أسواق الطاقة العالمية وترفع
أسعار الطاقة العالمية بالكامل مما يعني المزيد من
الأموال في الخزائن على المدى القصير
وهذا ما حدث حقًا من أجل
هذه المنطقة من ناحية أخرى مع كل
عدم الاستقرار العالمي يصبح من الصعب
التخطيط للتوترات الجيوسياسية
أعلى لذلك لن أقول أي شيء
سهل للغاية بشأن الوضع الحالي
لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
مع كل ما يحدث حولها
يحاولون التحرك أيضًا  من
الاعتماد على النفط إلى
الطاقة المستدامة والمتجددة ، ما مدى صعوبة أنه
بينما يعيش العالم كله في
فترة من عدم الاستقرار ، فإن
هذا التحول الذي يتعين على العالم
إجراؤه هائل إنه معقد
وهذه المنطقة تواجه تحديًا بشكل خاص
بسبب هذا لأن هذا هو  مركز
الهيدروكربونات للاقتصاد العالمي بأسره ،
لذلك لا يوجد شيء سهل حول هذا الأمر ، ومن ناحية أخرى ،
هناك الكثير من الجهد
بالطبع في الإمارات في المملكة العربية السعودية
في البلدان الأخرى لنقول ما
يمكننا فعله وكيف يمكننا الاستفادة على سبيل المثال من
الطاقة الشمسية التي  من الواضح أنه
مصدر ضخم آخر لهذه
المنطقة وهذا يحدث بالفعل
تقنيات جديدة ، أكبر
منشآت شمسية في العالم تجري
هنا تمويل جديد للبحث
والتطوير ، كل هذا مثير للغاية ولكن
النقطة التي توضحها هي أيضًا
مهمة للغاية ما هو مطلوب هو
الاستثمارات الضخمة التي ستربط
منطقة الخليج بأوروبا مع الهند بالصين
سواء كانت في الهيدروجين أو في
الإلكترونات الخضراء لمسافات طويلة والتي
تنتقل عبر مسافات طويلة
لنظام الطاقة المتجددة ، يمكن أن يحدث هذا
ولكنك بحاجة إلى التعاون من أجل ذلك
تحتاج إلى استقرار جيوسياسي لذلك نحن
لا نملكها الآن ولكننا بحاجة إليها ،
أعتقد أن أوروبا التي لديها صفقتها الخضراء
يجب أن تتحدث مع دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي ، مرحبًا
بتصدير بعض أشعة الشمس إلينا
لأننا لا نملك نفس أشعة الشمس
التي لديك ، فلنستغرق وقتًا طويلاً-
التزام المدى معًا
لبنية تحتية كبيرة مترابطة ، سيكون هذا
منطقيًا من وجهة نظري ، لكن
أوروبا من الناحية الجيوسياسية تقول آه علينا حماية
أنفسنا لذلك لا نريد أن نكون
متصلين ، انظروا إلى ما حدث
لخط أنابيب نوردستروم الذي كانت الولايات المتحدة في
التقارير الأخيرة هي  واحد
فجرها ، نظرًا لكل من يتحدث
عن بنية البنية التحتية لمسافات طويلة
ولكننا بحاجة إليها ، فهذه هي
اللغز حقًا في الوقت الحالي ، نحتاج
إلى إيقاف هذه الحروب ، نحتاج إلى
تعاون إقليمي كبير إذا أردنا
الذهاب  لإنجاز
كل الأشياء التي نحتاج إلى إنجازها ، لكن
القادة السياسيين للأسف هم
أكثر في الحرب والصراع قصير الأجل أكثر
مما هم في حل مشكلة طويلة الأجل ،
ما هي التداعيات إذا
استمرت الأمور كما هي الآن ما هي
التداعيات التي تقول في  بعد مرور 10 سنوات
على الموسم إذا وقفنا في طريق
الصراع هذا ، أعتقد أنه لا يمكننا المبالغة في تقدير
المخاطر لأننا لسنا فقط في
صراع مستمر نحن في صراع
متصاعد ، انظر إلى الحرب في
أوكرانيا كل شهر أو شهرين ماذا  كان من
المفترض أن يكون حدًا في التسلح
يتم إهماله جانبًا ، لا لا لا لا الدبابات ، حسنًا
الدبابات ، لا توجد طائرات مقاتلة تعرف
ربما طائرات مقاتلة في حالة
تصعيد خطير يحدث نفس الشيء
في شرق آسيا نفس الشيء
يحدث في هذا  تصعيد الخطاب
خطير للغاية بشأن تايوان ، على سبيل
المثال ، لا أريد أن أرى تايوان هي
أوكرانيا التالية حيث اندلعت الحرب
بين عملاقين قوتين ، لكن هذا
هو الخطر في الوقت الحالي ليس
فقط المواجهة المستمرة وخسارة
كل المكاسب  التعاون ولكن
في الواقع مخاطر
التصعيد الخطير بشكل غير عادي ما هي
أفكارك حول أه
الأجيال الحالية من الدولارات العالمية التي
يواجهونها العديد من التحديات التي
يواجهونها البطالة هم يواجهون العديد من
التحديات الأخرى ماذا سيحدث في
السنوات القادمة لهذه الأجيال إذا كانت
الأمور  أكمل كما هو الآن
أود أن أقول لجيل الشباب
في أي مكان سواء كان ذلك في
دول الخليج أو المنطقة العربية أو
الولايات المتحدة أو في البرازيل حيث كنت
قبل أسبوعين
أحصل على تعليم جيد لأن العالم
معقد
ستحتاج إلى مهارات لأعمالك
المستقبلية
فقط للبحث
عن أشخاص لديهم مهارات أو أشخاص
لديهم نوع من العمل الغاشم الذي تعرفه
وهو ليس مستقبلًا ، وبالتالي فإن التعليم
في رأيي هو النقطة الأولى
وهذا لأننا  نحن في
عصر يحركه العلم والتكنولوجيا بشكل كبير
لأن العالم معقد ولأن
الهياكل الاقتصادية القديمة
معطلة بشدة ، فسوف يتغيرون من
يعرف ما سيحدث في المستقبل
ولكن امتلاك المهارات سيكون أمرًا
ضروريًا من وجهة نظر الفرد  من
وجهة نظر أو وجهة نظر جيل